but first the Bolton red herring that's
the focus of tonight's angle I'm
beginning to think I'm just a complete
masochist because I was back on Capitol
Hill today to sit for the second time in
the Senate gallery and observe this
travesty of an impeachment trial while
of course it was great to hear from the
defense team especially Dershowitz his
tour de force constitutional argument
tried just referenced I walked away even
more disgusted over what the Democrat
House has done to America and if it's
even possible I'm more outraged that the
forced Squishy senators and the
Republican Party are toying with
prolonging this national nightmare in an
utterly predictable turn the resistance
media went gaga when word leaked last
night that John Bolton supposedly
dropped a bombshell a leaked secondhand
account of his upcoming book the media
was sure that this would alter the
course of Trump's impeachment bombshell
revelations from former national
security adviser John Bolton explosive
new details Oulton bombshell who has
just absolutely shaken Washington a
seismic shock hit Capitol Hill like a
thunderbolt Republican senators
reportedly are feeling blindsided by
this could change the course of
president Trump's impeachment trial I
think this is a game changer it's always
a game changer right always a game
changer with Trump we got him now let me
just say one thing as someone who's
actually written five books working with
some of the top publishing houses in the
United States as I have I know how this
little game goes let me explain it to
you it's all about hype because
publishers have to hype a few choice
tidbits in desperate hopes that they're
gonna make back the advance they
probably shouldn't have shelled out in
the first place noting that John Bolton
writes in a book or would testify to
frankly during the Senate trial changes
the basic facts that all 100 senators
know let me go through some of them with
you number one president Trump did sell
javelin ante
tank missiles to Ukraine Obama never did
here's the other thing they got their
money long before schedule they got all
their money why is in Germany paying
why isn't UK paying why isn't France
bang why aren't the European nations
bang why is it always the sucker United
States
that's exactly by the way how he started
his call was Olinsky just hitting the
NATO member nations for not chipping in
more that was how the call started no
one ever talks about that number two on
September 25th President Trump did meet
with ukrainian President zalenski and
expressed his desire to do so on a
number of occasions before that
including on the July 25th phone call
president Trump invited president
Solinsky to an in-person meeting on
their initial April 21 call on May 29
President Trump since it sent a
congratulatory letter again inviting
President zalenski
to the White House then on July 25th
president from personally invited
President Solinsky to participate in a
meeting for a third time give us a date
and we'll work that out three separate
invitations for a meeting all made
without any preconditions fact number
three the Ukrainian president never
announced an investigation into the
Biden's or buries m'a now numbers one
and two happened the meeting was Olinsky
and the military aid was Greenland
without szalinski ever having announced
he was investigating the Biden's and
buries m'a oh let's not forget number
four zolensky said he was not pressured
that the call was normal zalinsky
himself contradicted the Democrats wild
theory saying that he never felt
pressure to conduct an investigation
into the Biden's and didn't even know
that the aide was held up until the end
of August now the Democrats answer to
that was well let's just insult our ally
president Solinsky doesn't want to be
used this upon years when be drawn into
u.s. politics
but this point he feels he has no choice
he's lying that was a nice way of saying
szalinski was lying
nice going Adam now if Donald Trump
really wanted to hold up military aid
for an investigation of Ukrainian
corruption the Biden's
let me tell you Ukraine wouldn't have
their javelins right now they wouldn't
have them with zero evidence of criminal
intent on the part of the president
remember now he knew that 15 people were
listening to this phone call on July
25th for goodness sakes the house has
just left with hyperbole hearsay and
conjecture any honest senator knows that
the president was 100% within his right
as chief executive officer of the United
States to be concerned about corruption
in foreign aid in the entire process
whether involves the Biden's or doesn't
involve the Biden's and if he decides
that certain aid needs to be delayed a
bit while he gathers more facts well so
be it it's his call he was elected
president to do what he did is neither
illegal nor unconstitutional remember he
ran on safeguarding our tax dollars in
foreign affairs at NATO at the UN in
Iraq and even in Central America
this past summer the administration
paused reviewed and in some cases
canceled hundreds of millions of dollars
in foreign aid to Afghanistan El
Salvador Honduras Guatemala and Lebanon
at the very same time that the Ukraine
aid was paused now do you do all that to
help his re-election chances so he looks
like he's tough on immigration you see
how this argument could go and frankly I
was thinking about this sitting back
watching this when I wasn't in the
Senate gallery just at home watching us
from day one what this is really all
about is that the globalists and the
Obama holdovers in the Trump
administration that were burrowed deep
inside were infuriated by him from day
one because Donald Trump dared to
challenge the status quo
the bloated foreign aid budgets that
send billions overseas to ungrateful and
corrupt nations well we at home are
driving over rusted rusted out bridges
and we fly out of dilapidated airports
most regular people watching this
impeachment thing go wait a second we're
giving all that money to Ukraine are you
kidding me less than two months after
Trump was sworn in he with his
nationalist message was enraging the old
foreign policy establishment we are
going to propose to reduce foreign aid
and we are going to propose to spend
that money here and career civil
servants likee ivanovitch and ven minh
they prefer a world where their foreign
policy judgments reign supreme
they're never questioned in the budgets
keep growing and growing and growing
because people like that they kind of
fancy themselves as global sophisticates
smarter than the president smarter than
you that's for sure and that's for john
bolton
well it's really disappointing if he
ends up being just another think-tank
type trying to cash in on his time in
the White House yeah I like Bolton he's
been on the show a number of times but
he's a neocon who never should have been
hired by Trump in the first place
but again as you heard tonight from the
impeachment team policy differences
should not lead to an impeachment and
the only reason anyone cares about what
Bolton has to say is because he was
Trump's national security adviser period
we do not need to hear from him or read
what he writes again none of what he
could say and none of what he could
write could change the facts as they
occurred it is long past time to put an
end a merciful end of this impeachment
Fiasco now I say this by the way despite
the fact that impeachment has been a
huge ratings boon to the Ingraham angle
and frankly all of Fox News Congrats to
all my colleagues now if you're a
senator and if you've listened to both
sides the past week and neither telling
us you still haven't decided how you're
going to vote in an Ultima
verdict here's my message to resign you
shouldn't be in the Senate with rare
exception the same familiar arguments
are being made every day over and over
again excuse me where's everybody going
to gobblers knob it's Groundhog Day it's
still just once a year isn't it it's
almost here
if only this trial was 1/100 as
entertaining as that movie only Bill
Murray were up there well you get the
sense don't you that the handful of
moderate Republicans they're enjoying
their hamlet routine right now a little
bit too much people like Mitt Romney
Suzanne Collins Lisa Murkowski I'm sure
they're great people
nothing personal against them but do
they consider this moment a moment to
like show tucked Chuck Todd in the new
york times that they're the good
republicans they're they're respectable
republicans not like trump yet long
after their one-night stand with the
liberals ends their constituents will
see their posturing for what it is a
walk of shame allowing the circus to
continue for months is what will be here
for months if this continues of
witnesses means allowing the people's
business to languish it's a bad move
lets them to call the vote now they want
to they want to vote to convict Trump
then live with the consequences the
Senate switchboard is 202 2 2 4 3 1 2 1
2 2 4 3 1 2 1 we're gonna put that up
throughout the show tonight I want you
to make a phone call tell them how you
feel you're paying their salary they
work for you not the other way around
again as to the GOP fence sitters I'll
personally fly out to cover your town
halls I'll be there reporting on them if
you're brave enough to have any after a
vote to drag this thing out further Utah
has got to be experiencing a wicked case
of voters remorse I'm sorry Bolton's a
red herring
so is
the entire idea of calling witnesses
Paulo sees Democrats wouldn't pursue
those same witnesses in the house
certainly not taking a legal route to do
so if you want to remove a US president
on the facts that are now indisputable
and you want to do it nine months before
an election and you want to side with
Schiff and Nadler against your own
constituents your constituents who are
enjoying a thriving economy in a want
government to get back to the stuff that
really matters
then go ahead be my guest go do it then
I have another idea
just ask Jeff Flake how life is after
the Democrats no longer had any use for
him and that's the angle